well unlv has launched a new stem summer
camp for middle school students with a
fun twist focusing on technology in the
industries that drive our city
entertainment and hospitality mary jane
belliesa is live at unlv this morning to
show us more about these cool camps for
kids good morning mary jane
good morning sheri you know i was able
to catch up with these middle school
students on the second week of camp and
you know it was really just fun and
exciting to see what they were doing and
what it was all about the goal is to
show students and help them overcome the
negative stereotypes surrounding stem
and show them that it did definitely be
a ton of fun students are engaging in a
variety of activities including tours of
the university labs and even a trip to
the mgm to meet with the jab milwaukees
it's a chance to jump into hands-on
learning projects to develop their
creative ideas the lab is also free for
ccsd middle school students giving
everyone an opportunity to join and
students and mentors tell me they're
excited to see where their progress is
at the end of the camp
well what interests me in stem is the
amazing fact that it's just it's about
the discovery of the world around us and
also it's very cool to learn about the
lights and rgb technology i think it's
better to get them more exposed now and
like see how like stem is exactly
because i feel like in middle school or
like where they are right now
it's sometimes their math is kind of
boring or plain or just like how the
school is but like this is more hands-on
engaged see like what the actual like
circuits are i get to test them out and
like help them explore what they want to
do in the future
the lab it has about 40 middle school
students enrolled right now and it's
taking place for three weeks until the
end of june and you know towards the end
of camp on a final project that will
give them the chance to showcase
everything they've learned and what they
did and it's really exciting and of
course a lot more opportunities with
those doors opening up for them for the
future as well reporting live from unlv
mary jane ballisa live local now